the thing that really actually i think
became
the eye opener here in silicon valley is
with remote work when people stopped
showing up to their offices
because the commute became so oppressive
in silicon valley specifically
right you you had these kids coming here
to take 150 or 200
000 development job they would live in
the city for four thousand dollars a
month
for a one bedroom they would get on a
bus for an hour and a half
go to facebook come back for an hour and
a
half
and so they're leaving the city from
whatever it is
8 a.m until 8 pm can you imagine
somebody
doing a three hour commute somebody who
makes two hundred thousand dollars a
year
it's bonkers like you're living life
wrong right like
this is not the model of a great life
a hundred percent and i think this is
one of those aspects of
our entire approach to work ethics so to
speak or what qualifies as
hard work that it's just oddly
mind-blowing i think on the same tangent
when i first read that marissa mayer was
bragging about the fact that she was
working 120 hours a week and she could
do this by being strategic with
her bathroom breaks i was like wait
you're an executive at one of the most
successful companies in the world
and arguably you have worse working
conditions
than a slave in egypt
how is this like why would you subject
yourself
to such a degree of uh
sort of poor working conditions it just
it blows my mind and i think it's one of
those
key regressions that if you look over so
the decades you look back to like
what were the aspirations of the
white-collar workers
or the managers in like 1980 or 1970 it
was to take off early and go to the golf
course and enjoy life and i don't know
have yeah i don't know a drink at 4 pm
right
it wasn't like hey how can i stay at
work
for as many hours as possible um because
that's my
only source of satisfaction and meaning
in life
right i think we've really just took
taken a
seriously bad turn on that uh on that
road
now if a person is an elite athlete
uh navy seal an artist and they pursue
their
art basketball you know ice skating
whatever it is they're doing
training for the olympics whatever and
they do it for 60 70 80 hours a week
and the time passes really quickly and
they love it you don't have a problem
with that
first of all i have a problem with the
analogy because it's not true
if you look at any serious athlete none
of them are training 70 or 80 hours a
week on any sustained
sense of meaning of the word they have
these
enormous breaks i was just talking to my
wife i'm not a big fan of
american football nfl but we were just
talking about
the season is over and then i was like
when do they start up again like in
march or whatever yeah she was like no
they started in september
like big long range more than anyone
know that you need
huge amounts of break there's been a ton
of studies done on this on for example
the
impact of sleep there's a great company
in chicago i think it's called
sleep advisors oh man i should know this
hopefully we can put it in the show
notes but
they consult for major franchises nfl
nba and so on they've quantified just
the
dramatic effects you get from getting
better sleep getting better rest
that simply pushing all day
every day all week all year that's not
how you make a great athlete you make a
great athlete by doing
concentrated concert lessons and then
you have tons of rest
yeah i think this goes for everyone
regardless of whether you're a musician
or you're an athlete or whatever you
need down time
you need sort of a creative respite when
it's
a creative pursuit you need physical uh
respite when it comes to that i
work out with a trainer who's trained
olympians and one of the things he
always goes on and on about it like dude
training four days in a row is just
going to destroy your body
you're not going to actually end up
being a better athlete you're not going
to end up being better at anything
and i think it's some of those lessons
that lie just beneath the surface of a
story of say michael jordan like oh he
was the first one at the gym and he was
the last one to leave
that story has some qualifications that
we would be wise to to take into account
yeah i mean kobe was known for just a
relentless
day a year work ethic i think michael
jordan was known more for
going and playing blackjack till 6am and
then going to the gym and still winning
the game
he was almost like he was handicapping
himself he was so good
he just would stay out all night no that
one in that case it happens to be true
he was no no no no no no i i get the
part
i take the part of like him playing back
blackjack until 6am yeah i don't take
the part about
kobe working out uh what 12 hour days
for 365 days a year that just doesn't
happen